hey guys welcome back to quiz Lavallee
today I'll be first working on some
loose ends that I still really needed to
tie together like some small unfinished
buildings some back sides some paths
work and actually a lot of gardening
especially in this area around here
which I'm actually very happy with how
it turned out in the end and in the
second part of the video I'll actually
be building a weenie again for the
weenie fans out there it's something
which I wasn't really planning to do
that much but I had an idea to make a
triumphal arch for quite a long time and
only at this point actually go to it and
well it's not going to be that big it'll
still be kind of central and iconic
thing for their Roman area and a bit of
a small sidestep to get back into the
Roman area as well though I will still
really need to get back to those general
paths and park layouts and foliage parts
that I've really skipped at this point
still in future episodes so I'll be
working still less of in a less linear
way of doing certain areas at a time and
focusing on certain buildings each
episode but also do some more scattered
around work like I'm doing over here
with just a lot of smaller making the
entire park come together as I would
always say really which was actually
quite a lot of fun in the end as well
and one of the things which are actually
surprisingly easy to do but also a lot
of fun to do is to make these little one
tile fences and see how you can make
them with the objects that we have at
the moment and just copy those buildings
over to make one entire fence that sort
of looks like it's an actual functioning
fence and you can do a lot of things
with these fences you can just put a lot
of objects on them and copy them over to
make this sort of round fence which
really flows with the paths which is
very easy to do but it's actually a lot
of fun so I tried a couple of versions
of those as well but this has to be
really one of my favorites with just one
simple white beam a little roof border
thing not entirely sure what it's called
but it's from the sandstone roof and the
balcony is the very small iron work back
balconies just we have that bit of a
fence texture on there as well
and I also wanted to really get into
some gardening of this area which was
also quite a lot of fun especially since
this is really the well really that the
first part of the park in a way I wanted
to make sure that I actually got some
more slightly more fancy foliage in here
much like you were kind of seein Disney
but not quite since this is not a
planned park but has a much more organic
layout so I'm still not going entirely
disney-esque
on that not to mention that it's really
hard to do that with just a couple of
plants that we have at the moment but
it's still a lot of fun to just try
different things with those plants that
we have at the moment as well so I was
actually quite happy with that little
clock thing over there in the end now
over here I wanted to try an idea for a
small sideways fountain like at the
moment we only have the round fountains
which really meant to be placed in the
center of a square really it feels and I
was hoping I mean obviously I can't get
into the more actual functional details
of it and can't actually have small
water spouts and things like that
but just as a small idea I want to test
having these double fountains over here
the small sideways fountain with this
little wall it's a mermaid which doesn't
really work out well for the theme but
just as a general idea have this small
fountain set up sideways with the rock
work around here since I basically also
had not much of an idea what to fill
this in with which is part of having a
sort of organic layout it's really easy
to just make a park with an organic
layout or at least for me there usually
isn't much of a strategy to it it's just
kind of layouts things as you go and see
how you can like lay them out and things
where you're happy with how they're laid
out but you inevitably always end up
with these small spaces that you can't
quite fit an attraction in but you do
want to do something with them and the
last thing I actually want to do is to
have very dense foliage out there
because it's wow it definitely helps to
make things look a little bit more
natural and a bit more inviting I don't
want to clog everything up with foliage
and want to keep some things with some
lower brushes lower bushes or as in some
different details as well I basically
just
really want the park to become a jungle
not to mention that I do still have a
couple of sight lines which I really
want to keep in mind and one of them is
also the tower at the entrance so just
by keeping this area a bit more open and
having no trees over here you can
actually see the tower along the main
streets from the little plaza in front
of the Alpine building station and the
Alpine Coaster station I should say
which is not a really huge - but it's
just one of those sight lines which I
really wanted to keep in there and it
just makes you feel like you're not just
in this very small part of the park with
foliage all around it but more than it's
or one home and you can very slightly
see how certain areas transition into
other areas rather than just having a
quick forest and war of trees and let
that be its because that's I don't know
just that just feels like a much more
cheap and easy way to get along these
things when you can get much more out of
them and much more interesting of a flow
of this area basically by just keeping
it a little bit more open it's also in a
sense a way to sort of emulate the way
that real paths flow or at least I try
to do so because this is obviously a
thing which I've complained about before
but it's something which I just have to
keep in mind at the moment is that the
path the path system in the game has
many issues but one of them theme park
wise is that real theme park paths are
very wide and really just seas of
concrete with a couple of obstacles and
planters and rides in the middle of them
but they aren't really small paths that
go through foliage it's more or less the
other way around there is just a lot of
paths everywhere and there's some
foliage here in there with some
buildings and scenery as well which you
have these very large open areas with
paths which is hard to actually get to
in the game and which I also try to at
least get in as much as I can without
having it look very awkward and forced
if that makes any sense at all anyway I
wanted to very quickly finish the
backsides of these buildings in a more
sophisticated manner than what I had
before since before I thought that you
wouldn't really be able to see these
buildings but it turned out which is
point
something that I'm really glad about
that these trees do actually get higher
than the that these buildings do
actually go higher than the trees which
I tried to place to cover them up over
there so I wanted to just get some very
simple details on them on the backside
here
just so when you approach the Roman area
from the park entrance you can see these
Roman houses just above the trees as a
sort of hints of what's to come in the
area I guess and itami which I couldn't
really avoid so I really just wanted to
theme them as well and just rather than
break the immersion here just go along
with the idea of having these things
come over the trees a little bit not to
mention that on that little part on the
side there I do in a theme it's a little
bit and not make it just the transition
path between areas but actually make it
a proper part of the Roman area by
adding a Roman restaurants at some point
in the future over there but that's
something for the next episode and I
probably shouldn't really talk about
that quite yet since I'm not getting to
that yet because this is the area where
I am going to have the triumphal arch
just because I felt that this would be
the best place to have it it's also an
area where I felt I wasn't really sure
what I wanted to do with it because the
main issue with this area is that
obviously the part with the dive coaster
is raised and the rest of the park is
much lower than that and I needed the
parts to actually go down to the left of
the rest of the park and it's hard to
really keep like the wide floor plus a
path style as you have to go down and
have these small Road small paths that
will have to go down over the rocks over
there so instead I figured I might as
well at the arch over here and create a
large open area to sort of have the arch
as a centre point we need over here
rather than trying to do some stuff on
the rocks like having more buildings or
closing it up in that way which is a bit
of a risk I read I really wasn't sure if
I wanted to do it this way because if it
doesn't really work out I would end up
basically with this enormous sea of just
rocks over here and obviously since
there is since there is the sloped paths
over there I can't really work with
the flat rides or anything either to
make it a little bit more filled up but
that's something to also get to next
episode but yeah for the arch itself
it's very very heavily inspired by
Constantine's arch in Rome pretty much I
think it's not only Roman Forum but it's
very close to the Colosseum I believe
and it's really one of the most
beautiful if not the best I think
triumphal arches that are out there and
it's something which I just wanted to
remake with having the three arches it's
very much like the triumphal arch in
Paris which is arguably the most famous
one but that one only only has one arti
in the middle of it and I just really
liked having these arches on the side as
well and it is something that I really
wanted to try here it's an idea which I
wanted to try for quite a long time
really haven't done yet and at this
point I just figured well might just
throw a shot at it and see how well it
goes and it might just end up in an
episode and here we are that's basically
what happened though I did [ __ ] up a
couple of things like this a little
pillar over here where I completely
forgot how I actually positioned deep
these beams to make a proper pillar out
of them but yeah this is in the end what
it became what became of its basically
now this arch does really differ from
Constantine's one in a number of ways
because of a number of reasons which is
well first I really just wanted to make
my own type of arch and at least not
completely copy one in real life I also
just had to do so since there are just
certain pieces that I would need that I
well we just don't have in the game at
least not yet and sometimes just out of
convenience because some things are
easier to do in a different way the
pillars actually are an example of that
in real life these arches between the
arches have a little bit of space like
the walls are quite wide between the
different arches but since there aren't
any HOF tile walls in the game and only
for higher walls with you which you
obviously can't really make those very
narrow walls between the arches I just
placed those pillars in the middle of
them to still be able to keep the arches
at some distance from each other but
that's also why
did place the central arch on a separate
grid on a separate building and made
that one and a half yeah one and a half
tiles wide so that I could still get
those quarter tile wide differences
between the different arches which is
actually what made a pretty big
difference literally and figuratively in
the end with how the arch looks by just
having that small or well very thick
wall in between the arches much like
real arches really do have so yeah
that's really the general idea behind it
and aside from that it was just a lot of
trying different things and seeing
what's really possible and what I could
add it was in this case more of a
looking and the pieces in game and
seeing what I could do with it
then looking what I would like to build
and then looking at the pieces in game
to see how I could build that certain
thing like usually I come up with
something that I would like to build and
then see how I can use the pieces in the
game to actually achieve it which is
also how I would recommend anyone to
build anything at any point in time
because it's much easier to start
thinking out of the box which certainly
uses that you can have four objects like
I don't think anybody comes up with the
idea to just use a chimney as a pillar
out of the blue it was pretty much an
idea that also spawned from the fact
that I was looking for a certain type of
shape for a pillar and it turned out
that the chimney was the best thing to
go with and when it comes to that but in
this case it was a little bit different
since I had a general idea of what I
wanted to do with the arch but apart
from that I really just wanted to look
at the pieces in the game and see what
things were actually most fit there were
actually a couple of things which did
positively surprised me like the fact
that these scenery pieces are actually
very useful for the pillars I wasn't
really happy with the barrels though but
it actually turned out that's the little
puffer fish thing or Blowfish whatever
it is is actually pretty handy as long
as there's actually that thing above it
for the Leafs because basically there
or the couple of different types of
classic pillows and I wanted to really
have Corinthian pillars which have
leaves on them which is pretty much
impossible I was afraid but it turned
out that the little puffer fish scenery
item actually did have some leaves
underneath it it just had a puffer fish
on top of which which which I could
really do without but in the end at
least the ridge above the pillars ended
up doing a pretty good job of pretty
much making the perfect fish whatever
fish it really is I'm no biologist to
make that damn thing unvisible and make
this at least a little bit more
realistic so there was a bit of
struggling with different things there I
also have to say that a lot of time was
in the end spent on fine-tuning these
and this arch since I've really got the
base down quite quickly
and had a certain idea of what I wanted
to do but when it comes to the really
minor details it really took a lot of
messing about with things to actually
get to a point where I was happy with
how it looks like at this point in time
I wasn't really too happy with the top
of the building since it seemed a bit
too narrow I do like it somewhat but
it's not Roman and it's not even a shape
that I very commonly see so I wanted to
make that a bit higher as well and when
it comes to certain other things and
real life these things I just dressed up
with lots of sculptures along the side
lots of murals and also some letters and
numbers probably alongside the top as
well to whomever they were erected for
or whoever was narcissistic enough to
want to have an arch somewhere on the
plaza somewhere and obviously I can't
really get those things in so there was
just a lot of just opening random
scenery items in the game and seeing
when I could actually do with them the
general idea behind this arch was really
though to tie the Roman area a bit more
together as well like like I said before
having that little sloped area with the
rocks where I basically couldn't do
anything because there's a slope pot and
you can't really attach buildings around
it very easily and it's very awkward
since you can't make a cross see here
either
and like on the other side I got rid of
that problem by basically having the
zero-g roll go over the path having that
small aqueducts and just having a
passage through buildings but it wasn't
quite so easy to make that here so I
want to tell me to at least be able to
expand the Roman area into this
direction but not make it feel like
there are two separate parts like you
have the part which is high up and you
have the part which is lower over here
and that there is no connection really
between them and I guess this was really
my only idea I had to make that happen
like an arch which from here really
makes like all the different paths
actually go toward this arch which is
quite funny considering these saying I
don't know if this is actually in an
English saying as well but considering
me saying that all roads lead to Rome
somewhere but yeah the that's basically
why I felt like I wanted to have this
thing basically as an object which you
could see from the entire area and be
more or less the center point of it
there is probably a better word to
describe it but uh probably said that
enough at this point in time but yeah
that's basically the general idea behind
it and then alongside this thing there
are still a couple of ideas which I have
and a couple of new years which I also
got from Commons which I'm still
thinking about the first thing which
I'll add around here is a restaurants
and I'll probably also have the which
like flat ride the one round flat right
which I haven't placed in the park yet
which I really felt fits quite well with
the Roman theme somehow I have no idea
why I feel that but besides I still need
a flat rights in here somewhere but also
an idea which I got so many requests to
make a Colosseum or which is something
that I might feature in some way but I'm
definitely not going to make a Colosseum
not even a small and I just feel like oh
come on that has done like two amazing
of a job at it already to even try doing
it and I don't really see much of a
point even but what I do love to make
perhaps is an amphitheater or
it's a pronounced right anyway yeah like
one of these little theaters much like
the I think it's Marco Polo theater in
Busch Gardens Williamsburg
because you see theaters a lot in theme
parks obviously and I don't even have
one over here at the moment and what
better theme to do it with then and
roman-themed really I feel so even if I
won't make it a Coliseum which is very
likely I do still want to make a simple
theater alongside the side of this Plaza
somewhere and so basically it will be
filled up with rides and places to go
alongside all of the size of this Plaza
I don't just make it a simple Plaza in
the middle of nowhere which would make
the the arch in the middle quite an
underwhelming thing really so this will
be quite a centerpiece for in this area
but then again I won't really expand the
Roman area much beside that I've been
thinking about the dark ride but I'm not
really sure if that's really manageable
in the time and if it's really worth it
to get the effort to actually build a
full dark ride which I if I do so I
would want to put a lot of efforts into
and I do want to finish this park before
the end of this alpha and also before it
completely crashes and before it reaches
terrible FPS or at least an unworkable
frame it so I probably won't be running
a dark ride so that will really be my
only plans for the Roman area it's
perhaps almost going to double in size
from what it is now or just a bit more
but it's not going to be that huge so
there will still be space left for
different themes and then I'll just have
to at some point decide what the best
themes are I haven't really tried to
much I've tried a couple of Dutch
buildings and as much as I would love to
do the theme I am a little less
confident that I connect [ __ ] and then I
Mia that I can actually do it then the
last time that I announced it since I
tried it and it didn't even work out
that well it's possible but only if you
stretch the theme very much and if you
try to keep it just to the basics it
just turns out very boring so I might do
it but just go not that realistic with
it and have more fantasy details to it
anyway but there are also some other
themes a Viking theme is a possibility
I've also been thinking about an Arabian
theme as similar to an Italian theme as
it is really and those are just the
things that are on my mind at the moment
anyway that's it for this episode
I'm not going to overview this thing
quite yet and I'll really save that
until this general Plaza is finished but
thank you guys for watching this episode
and see you later